So,
so the Mecca Medina distinction seems to be jury,
I would say both complicated and problematic because,
so,
so t tell me if I'm wrong.
Okay.
Because my understanding is that Mohammed spent most of the part of his life
that was associated with the establishment of Islam in Medina and northern neck.
And that it wasn't until he went to Medina that Islam actually became a force.
So back in Mecca,
although his doctrine appears to have been,
let's say,
more peaceful,
it was also much less successful as a,
as a both a religious and a political movement.
So then he left Mecca and I believe under pressure from the inhabitants,
at least to some degree,
moved to Medina.
And then that's when Islam became more,
uh,
more rep,
more revolutionary and expansive.
And so what do you see now I know that it isn't universally accepted among the
Islamic community that that Mecca Medina distinction is a reasonable one to make
because of course the presumption is that there's an essential unity of thought
across the doctrines.
But,
but given,
given your interpretation and I've read the a similar interpretation among
other,
among other people,
do you see,
what do you see as hopeful within the Islamic community with regards to bridging
the gap between the say the earlier works so to speak of Mohammed and the later,
the later more,
more revolutionary element of the,
of his actions and his faith.
Is there a way that that can be reconciled?
Well,
so dividing of Muslims into Mecca,
a set of Mecca,
Medina and modifiers,
that's not of course an official this thing except that anyone really wants to
give to you know who,
which individuals,
which Muslims uh,
at war with us.
And should we be worried about what about peaceful Muslim?
What about these other Muslims who are speaking up?
No,
what kind of labels we will give him.
If you said the word Islam most
as a Muslim,
what was the last thing that I look is that selected and in their selection who
justify their,
actually they said both methods.
Alondra to legacy in Mecca.
Because as I was,
if my sister tells me you've missed the pair,
you need to get up and say,
I was involved,
some of us for my parents say,
oh come on my relationship with a lot these intimate and unique,
maybe it's none of your business to tell him what to do.
And then she would come up with some other or some other Thursday.
But it's my easy to command and hold on,
I'm sorry.
But then the lithium was going to extent underused Decisely and I'm not the only
one the other scholars like and that there are many other scholars
who needs to see a window piece.
I think his mom.
Okay,
okay.
Additional or the culture as a civilization and at the same time putting to ban
this violin,
providing courses within Islam.
Try and do that.
Then you'll go to see your work to make a list of all the concepts
that we really don't have any problem with people being told to pay five times a
day or is this letter or in the [inaudible] and all sorts of,
you know,
religious features I think don't have a problem.
Well,
all of,
that's what they did.
That's the Mecca and Medina,
as you said,
a political philosophy.
They're dishonest.
And the literacy Muhammad,
we just them and that's,
and that's exactly when it was loud.
Okay,
I'm successful and this is just today I tried to end it in and they say
Paul
to be
what to be emulating.
So that's I think where you were saying,
you know,
the neck of the unit and Poker Martha
classification that we applied social sciences has its problems.
But this was sort of simplifies because it focuses oh,
after you should what it should.
Okay.
So you see this as an externally applied,
um,
uh,
a category system essentially useful that's useful for,
for,
for outsiders who are trying to assess the situation to determine who it is that
you're dealing with that might be regarded as an ally and who it is that you're
dealing with.
It might be regarded as a fault,
so to speak.
And that would be on the more militant end of things is that,
that,
that that's a reasonable way of looking at it.
That's reasonable.
That's a reasonable way of looking at it.
But also if you take the moderate versus extreme classification or
categorization that has become common placed,
it does is tell you what,
when we look at that model,
we think of people who are not using by us.
We're,
if you look at Medina,
you will see that there are hundreds of thousands of Muslims who do not apply
violence now,
but who do preach about and they do move peach,
the Makino legacies and they believe it should be.
It should be instituted.
And in places where the guests,
where you get a majority of these,
none of violence and the types,
the center,
this has applied and forces we alone.
So I think that the toms model is an extreme.
I just was not good enough.
They don't cover the well and they also don't,
they don't also seem to bear any relationship to the internal diet dynamics of
the faith itself.
So that that's also problematic.
Okay,
so does that,
because you have to keep going back to the theology,
you have to keep going back to the internal debate among Muslims are a on and
how to be late to the hospital.
So I personally think Mecca and Medina is much more useful as a tool,
as an external perceptual framework for understanding the problem we face is
Islam,
then x team versus versus white bread and all the,
all the other terms that we have.